it is a lazy Sunday morning you are idly
clicking around online as your phone
rings Sam a co-worker of yours that
you're friendly with s how you are and
makes hurried small talk with you you
typically only ever talk to him on the
phone when one of you needs a shift
covered so it's slightly awkward you're
waiting in anticipation for him to ask
you to come on in on short notice when
he beers the conversation in a
completely different direction how do
you feel about cats he asks my night
kittens a few weeks ago and i'm having
an awfully hard time finding a home for
the last one of the litter you don't
have any pets right it takes you a
moment to process this new information
in New caught off guard as he begins to
earnestly try to sell you on the idea of
taking the last kitten off his hands
it's not something that you had
specifically considered before and he
seems fairly insistent she's a real
sweetheart really loves people she's got
all her shots already taken care of and
the vet said she's healthy as a horse I
can bring her over I can bring her over
by your place tonight if you're
interested you look around your
apartment trying to picture a cat in it
as he continues to tell you about how
cute she is you tell them that this is
all kind of sudden and that you don't
have anything for the kittens set up
here and oh don't worry about that I can
bring over litter box and food and all
that since you'd really be helping me
out of a fix it's the least I could do I
just don't want to put have to put her
in a shelter you can't help but feel
like you're being guilt tripped but you
decide to give it some serious
consideration it does get awfully lonely
around your apartment and it might feel
less empty with a cat around however
since you've been feeling so down it
might not be a good idea to take all the
responsibility of a cat even if they are
fairly low maintenance what do you do
side note this clearly does not take
place in LA no cuz I you cannot afford
an apartment on your own well yeah and
and and finding one that you can afford
on your own is also going to be cool
with you having a pet yeah like that has
enough space for you to imagine a cat in
it yeah like this does not take place in
LA okay so we're going anywhere yeah
we're in like Minnesota yeah all right
oh oh we got two options off the 10
for the am take the cat knowing full
well that you can get that you can take
great care of it is not an option number
two decline even though you'd be totally
capable of taking care of it you're not
much of a cat person three become a cat
owner you could use the companionship
number four decline you're not in a good
enough place to be taking on more
responsibility right now um and number
five decline you don't like cats okay um
I have a qualifier question okay because
my answer that this would go if this if
I'm imagining this from my real life
perspective this answer would go one way
if I'm just in the shoes of of the
cypher of the game it would go a
different way so like I've allergic to
cats I can't take that cat oh yeah you
know I'm not gonna I can't hang out all
day with my face like a tomato yeah but
that's not on the board so the player
character is not allergic okay um where
the cat is a hypoallergenic cat [ __ ] you
got me yo do that that would be like
that's I go allergenic cabin then what
because this especially like what's was
this dude's name Sam Sam has all the
answers for all of my misgivings so he's
like not dude hypoallergenic there's no
way you you can't have you ever like
been in that position where it's like
someone someone has someone
automatically has the the counter to why
you wouldn't just naturally decline
something oh yeah so you know it's all
good I'll Drive you know i'll give you
gas money it's like so it all boils down
to do you want to or not yeah you don't
feel like a shitty person for saying you
would not want to and for that reason i
feel like under the circumstances I I
would let myself get talked into
becoming a cat here's my thing knowing
me in my day-to-day life 1 i'm just the
the nature of my lifestyle is not one
where i could take on a pet because i'm
never home yeah well it's the same it's
same here there's same for me
being that it's a cat like and I would
be stressed but I may be able to like
manage now at least feeding the cat a
few times a day yeah good now cat like
if it was a dog this question would go
very differently as the dog does need
attention the dog does need
socialization the dog does need to be
walked same thing with a bird apparently
birds if they're not socialized with
enough they freak out interested yeah to
read to my bird yeah well you probably
saved his life and he lived a long time
since I did you probably don't want um
so yeah so but a cat is kind of
self-contained so it's like even if you
have to spend a little you know even if
you have to like do overtime at whatever
your job is can you could not feel too
bad about leaving the Catalan because
cats are self-sufficient owyang a lot of
cats a lot of pets anyway have like
there's a two-tier food system where
it's like this bowl of kibbles gonna sit
out all day long for you to kind of
chawla on his you see fit and when I'm
home I'll feed you your like wet food
entree yeah but it's like they won't be
remiss for food yeah you you'll have
your mix of meow throughout the day and
then what I when it's dinner time you
will have a fancy fancy fees to sync
your whiskas into so I feel like if it
were me I would probably decline just
because I'm not in in the kind of place
to take on the responsibility of a pad
but that's considering that I but
necessary but tears thing in this game
you have more of a home base you like
you are home more often well yeah it's
like I had a player characters I'm
usually not prone to sitting at home as
much a long time yeah yeah um I was
saying I mean I would dislike decline
you're not saying a good enough place to
you know take on that responsibility
that is like what I would want to say I
just feel like I wouldn't let myself get
talked into taking yeah like but he
is me doing the metagame thing I think
this cat is basically a power oh [ __ ] i
think the cat is a power up because
later on the cat is going to become
basically like a therapy animal okay not
necessarily like you go get a therapy
animal vest on him but I feel like the
game is gonna pan out where the cat
loves lasagna the cat it will become
soothing to have somebody in your life
who hates Mondays as much as you do do
like we both don't want to go to work
today no um I think it's I think the
catch is because it is something that
you are sharing your home with that that
is relying on you it will become it will
become a motivator that'll get you up in
and a little more motivated well yeah I
feel like there's something about it you
know I'm a dog person but I feel like in
the psychological side of things you
know a dog is the guys like come on you
could yeah yeah where is like a cat is
sort of the dude you would look across
the room and you guys are just kind of
nodded each of them away yeah I know
right it's like I feel like when I feel
like give me that this is about someone
with depression I feel like having the
dog that comes up to you and look sad
and yeah it's like if you're down your
dog can tell and your dog gets sad when
you're sad and then that makes you feel
sadder can you say and then you feel sad
for making the dog sad then you like
shitty person cuz I'm making my friend
feel bad yeah I'm a shitty person cuz I
can't take care of this dog all this dog
wants is to walk and I didn't take the
dog for a walk because I'm a shitty
person whereas with the cat it just like
you know the worst that's gonna happen
with the cat is like you come home maybe
something scratched up or he has to walk
over your keyboard or it's in water
episode or is it nervous so I would say
we've got to take we're gonna take that
cab taking the cat depression cured you
give you did you want the game is there
a gameshark for this oh yes we address
can you enter like dr. Marius I'll just
be like okay san-x Zoloft wellbutrin
we'll be together
I wasn't something speedrun depression
quest all right okay cat all right next
what go to the party thanks ya did it
ten minutes to a moment fine John iced
conquered depression you accept the
offer of the kitten and hang up shortly
after making arrangements for when your
coworker can drop her off tonight let's
discuss the possibility of ending the
war tonight after hanging up you worry
about if you suddenly taken on the
responsibility and you can't handle and
hope you make a hope you don't make a
small animal suffer for it you're not
entirely sure what to expect and you
spend the rest of the afternoon
researching cat care online and trying
to think of a name oh man I hope we get
to enter the name oh [ __ ] alright you
think of a name okay the evening rolls
around and you hear a knock at your door
Oh startling you out of reading
Wikipedia entirely too hard you take i
like this version you take possession of
a small terrified black and white kitten
in a carrier along with everything you
need to start taking care of man this
guy really wanted you to take care he's
like here's a jungle gym here's some
kitty litter here's a year supply of
food just comes in with this true this
like u-haul trailer full of a petco
section so many amenities to wear like
to decline is just to out yourself as a
[ __ ] purse and then you just like it may
pulls out this giant wad of bills and
just starts making it rain all the money
you'll ever need to buy sand cat litter
and cat food in your whole life this
guy's just like prepared in the worst
way she bought you a robot that will
recap for you so basically it's like
he's just smiling at you be like now if
you tell me you don't want the cat
you're a yes yes oh [ __ ] you uh you take
her into your bedroom close the door and
open the door to the carrier excitedly
she cowers in the back of a new back off
feeling slightly defeated you remember
what you researched on introducing a kid
into a new home and leave her alone to
go mess around with your computer
hopefully checking over your shoulder
every so often to see if she has come
out yet she hides inside her carrier
periodically making sorrowful cat howls
long enough for you to start worrying
she already doesn't like you but by the
time you go to bed she's curled up at
the foot of it eyeing you nervously
before falling asleep over the next few
days you gain her trust and she begins
affectionately following you around
sleeping on you and hopping up on you
any time you sit down to do some work
alright body we got to care hell yeah
cat a choir unlocked character unlocked
cat it's late Friday afternoon and
quitting time is just around the corner
well why is quitting time yeah yes
because it's a nationally recognized
part of the day it's a national holiday
of every day a bright to take Oregon
because you've worked enough a bright
clear days giving way to a still
temperance evening you can hear your
co-workers all around you anxiously
making plans for their evenings and
weekends but you're really looking
forward to just going home and resting
after what's turned out to be a very
long and taxing work week just before
the end of your shift you get a call
from Alex it seems a group of your
mutual friends are heading out to a
nearby pub for dinner and drinks to
celebrate the end of the week and they
want to know if you'd like to come along
it's the end of the week so I want
something people know otherwise holy
[ __ ] only 50 more zzz's it no next year
throughout the whole year then we just
gotta do down like like a couple like
this is a couple like you know score
times is ever be dead all right required
one life two yeah it's like everything's
a milestone quitting time is like the
day version and then a week is like you
know the week and then you know at the
end of every year these people are
milestone obsessed yes like we've broken
it down you tentatively tell her that
you're emotionally exhausted from the
work week and a social outing like that
would just take too much out
you today you encouraged her to go and
have a good time since you know it's
been a while since she's gone out with
friends but the effort fierce feels
butyl since you know that she isn't
going to go without you a couple hours
later the two of you find yourselves in
a familiar position on the couch
watching comedy shows on Netflix a box
of pizza opened on the coffee table in
front of you as you look across the
couch eater you start to feel anxious
you feel bad about effectively forcing
the tool you just stay in tonight again
while you are always appreciative of
your partner's efforts to take your
feelings into account and help make sure
you're socially comfortable you
sincerely worried that you're holding
her back from enjoying a more fulfilling
relationship well she does seem to enjoy
spending time with you as the two of you
sitting comfortable almost contention
silence watching old shows you've each
scene two or three times before your
ever-increasing fear that your
relationship is becoming one sided with
more and more heavily on you you feel
more than ever like a burden or reward
to her and it's virtually impossible for
you to see what value you could possibly
offer to her return worst of all this
nagging fear has made you feel more
self-conscious than ever withdrawing
effort in words and you start to pull
away even from Alex herself what do you
do I'll tell you what you don't do you
know despite the bad times your
girlfriend sincerely loves you
relationships are a two-way street and
you resolve to always be there for her
like she has been for you but you can't
do that number to tell Alex how
important she is to you and enjoy your
evening also can't do that so number
three ask alex if she's happy with your
relationship or the [ __ ] don't say
anything you're already worried about
her being upset with you oh man oh man
this is a toughy this is a huffy bicycle
of a toughy yeah um whoa
um I feel like number two would be my
strategy but that is not all we can do
that we can't do that number two would
be my strategy yeah would same here okay
appreciate ya you you you good you you
could you I know you're doing me a solid
right now sit here on this couch
watching not The Cosby Show then oh that
was remind I've thought you were going
to say not the cosbys which was um no
not that part yeah oh no I I swear to
God I cannot imagine like what has
happened to not the cosbys since the
Cosby story is broken out since the next
installment isn't even a porno it's just
an apology dite meant and an apology
yeah like they they wrote the second
episodes the entire you know Huxtable
families gets on cosmic rays oh [ __ ] how
did you get in there have you been in
this whole time where America's in the
booth don't have a bad back to the
leading source of back pain I know yeah
one hundred percent of back pain comes
from the back this was not coming to bed
um hundred percent of back pain comes
from baby good hun % back pain comes
from beans and rice not missing you oh
[ __ ] um what are we gonna do this is a
pickle I feel word okay so three could
start a very uncomfortable conversation
which is why I feel like but less
extreme circumstance prevailed i would
probably wind up at four i I feel like
three could backfire very badly but
again it's like my mindset is still
always if I don't do it I'm gonna feel
bad having not
on it well yes like it's a proactive I
know just more like I just don't want to
stew in my own thoughts because I know
that's gonna get super uncomfortable
super fast yeah if I can like just do
something to interrupt me thinking on it
too much I'm gonna get [ __ ] up or if I
don't interrupt that I'm gonna get
[ __ ] up so I mean that's a proactive
shea/for thinking game strategy asking
is a proactive choice yeah it's an
active but this is depression quest
you're not supposed to be proactive you
have a medical condition that makes you
not proactive but this is an option and
you could beat the game our cat and our
proactivity could make us unpressed ekat
we we have the cat power-up so maybe
that's gonna give us like the extra mana
to power through this relationship
question that's the only like like
mythical thing though just just like
it's all really normal situations based
on depression but you also have to
collect and use mana yeah it's like it's
like you you got the cat you have the
you have the potion and now you cast so
are we are we are we okay okay if I cast
okay so we're gonna roll three yeah okay
ask alex if she's happy with her
relationship you look over at alex who
hasn't noticed you watching her yet and
you try to parse the expression on her
face you worried that it's one of sheer
boredom and bear tolerance you wonder if
she's thinking about all the fun things
she could have been doing tonight if she
wasn't trapped on this couch with you
ordering from the same three takeout
places we were always ordered from a
sense of disappointing of little hat
seth has about a sense of disappointed
or creeps over you as you picture what
the night could have been if you had
just accepted the invitation she had
made earlier I know this is a pretty
boring friday night for you are you
really happy being here with me I mean
being like this she turns to look at you
forehead wrinkled
Bonnie asked me that so often you feel
her body stiffened and pull away from
yours just a little well I I mean you
start but are unable to try and think of
how to answer [ __ ] we [ __ ] up we
[ __ ] up dude undo undo go back I don't
to take a stim pack can we can we like
can we use the cat as like as like one
on do it's like will forfeit the cat if
we could go back a step we traded the
CAD ok number one is crossed out it's
probably silly but it's reassuring when
I hear that we're on the same page
number two also crossed out I want to
make sure I'm right for you number three
is I know it's not what you usually be
up to before I don't know I guess like I
think I guess I get kind of worried when
you're getting that you're getting bored
sometimes number five never mind mom oh
I'd probably go i would probably three
this one yeah 3 sounds like like never
mind just too obvious 3 is a way out of
it without getting too deep into it and
it demonstrates like a base level of
sympathy yeah just like I'm sorry yeah
yeah it's also number 4 is I guess I get
kind of worried that you're getting
bored sometimes number 4 is number four
is digging more into the matter and the
matter is like you're feeling insecure
so number four is digging into
addressing that what you're feeling
insecure about but number four is also
like basically it all about you whereas
number three you kind of are with number
three years kind of making it a little
gliding a little easier because you're
you're appealing to Alex yeah what just
tragic louth of just judging by the way
this is sort of progressed I don't think
we we the cipher are equipped for number
four yeah I don't think we're equipped
for the the box that will open and yeah
I'll have to deal with we're not gonna
be able over ourselves we're not gonna
be
to withstand what comes out of going
down for so three sounds better Trey
pace I know it's not what you usually be
up to Alex friends what do you mean by
that I just mean you usually like going
out and doing things partying and stuff
you know she sighs and falls against the
couch isn't like I want to do those
things all the time I like nights into
just like everyone else she turns to you
frustration wearing on her face
sometimes I swear she feels like you
don't know me at all it's not that I
just your voice trails off and you
notice that she has an exasperated look
on her face that you've seen once or
twice when you have conversations like
this conversations where your poorly
expressing your own self-doubt and
insecurities seeking reassurance but
really feeling like you're making things
worse she sighs again this time louder
turning towards the flickering screen I
like spending time with you okay I
didn't I wouldn't be here the annoyed
tone in her voice makes you think
otherwise but you take it as a sign that
you should probably drop it for now and
you feel badly for upsetting things so
you drop this ain't no wait the oh [ __ ]
did they change yeah um I'll wait it's
the same on this page so I'll just read
off this page you are deeply depressed
even activities you used to enjoy hold
little or no interest for you and you
exist in a near constant state of
lethargy no you're not currently seeing
a therapist or not currently taking
medication for depression you're not
doing well yes it is a breezy Sunday
afternoon still still Sunday yeah I
think on a Sunday I think this is a new
Sunday okay you've allowed Amanda an old
friend from school that is in town for
the weekend to talk you into leaving the
house for coffee and ketchup yeah catch
up you meet her in a small cafe and talk
about what you've been up to since
you've last seen each other and you
can't help but feel like they're a lot
more accomplished and interesting than
you are whilst listening to them talk
about their life after school when is
your turn to brief them on your
activities you feel anxious and a shame
to give a very abbreviated version you
try to talk about your job as little as
possible and you feel incredibly boring
while you describe it despite her
expressing since you're interested you
in your life amanda has known you long
enough to read your moon tone of voice
she leans in to ask a question while
gently touching your hand a look of
genuine concern in her face what's wrong
do you not do number one suggest a
change of location confide in her
honestly do you not do number two test
the waters and open up a little hoping
she'll understand do you number three
insist that nothing is wrong and changed
the subject do univer full defensively
ask what she means by that do you never
find notice that your hands are shaking
haha plot twist oh no why is your hand
shaking um Oh are we are we horny for
Amanda Oh God like is is the is a
relationship with with is a relationship
with Alex gonna be in jeopardy oh [ __ ]
man like are we gonna do something rash
with Amanda to try and get out of the
fun I'm gonna act out are we gonna act
out are we gonna Bojack this are we
gonna vote Jack this no we can't we
can't you can't be the horsemen my in
like I kind of want to notice that my
hands are shaking because it's
observational and like that's something
that has to be addressed cuz that's like
a bad tell ya um uh I don't know I I
wouldn't get defensive probably yeah
defensive doesn't sound right and I
don't know I don't know if i would
actually insist that nothing is wrong
and just change the subject I'm Maya
again I would do number basically I
would do number one without asking for a
change in location yeah possibly number
two sounds more likely I'd probably too
I probably too but two is an option yeah
maybe them maybe that means when in real
life not as bad as as player character
yeah maybe maybe we were just you know
mildly yes maybe we actually don't feel
as shitty as we think we do this is
great
feel but it's like I feel bad for game
me yeah game me oh no at least he got
the cash he's you got that sick cat
where's the cat been what if the cat's
dead we haven't been home have we been
feeding the cat is the cat okay where's
the subplot about the cat I need to know
we're probably just thinking about the
CAD to avoid dealing with this stuff
with Amanda shed we're literally are we
really doing in that moment what like
happens in your brain works just like
this is really bad uncomfortable I
wonder my cat's okay let me think about
that instead and now my hands are
shaking um I guess number five you know
let's notice our hands yeah all right
notice damn hands it's such a small
question but feels like a blow to the
gut you surprise yourself when you
realize that you're tightly clenched
fists are now beginning to shake
slightly despite your best efforts you
feel tears begin to sting at your eyes
you tried to disguise this by tilting
your head up and praying that they'll
suck back in she suggests that you to
get out of there and you feel mortified
she's offers to go back to your
apartment with you but the two of you
end up taking in end up talking in her
car for two hours as the words just
poured forth from you Amanda seems
unsure of what to say at times but she
listens and rubs your back as you saw
bin Tahoe [ __ ] she asked if you'd gone
to a doctor about this and you admit
that you haven't she mentions that her
mother is seeing a very good therapist
in town and offers to ask her about it
they're not thrilled about the idea of
going to the therapist and even less
thrilled that Amanda might be telling
someone about your problems but she
persists and tells you that she'll email
you the doctors contact information
later in the week oh [ __ ] alright let's
let's go it's a glaringly sunny Monday
yeah and one of the few days that your
mother oh you're probably modern of a
brother mom's name Malcolm you know one
of the few days that your brother
Malcolm is in town and I'm Malcolm free
long enough for you to actually see each
other you have a dental appointment that
day but you make plans for him pick you
up afterward your appointment takes a
little longer than expected because your
dentist tells you that you started
grinding your teeth in your skip to a
worrying degree oh no
not doing well oh [ __ ] given how Earl
given how nearly everything in your life
has been feeling enormous and stressful
lately this doesn't come as a surprise
to you he suggests that you try to
reduce your stress levels and fits you
for a night guard it feels awkward and
too big for your mouth and you feel
embarrassed looking at your puffed out
face in the mirror with it in you finish
up the appointment in a hurry to leave
in a hurry and leave about half an hour
overdue for meaning you're always
punctual brother in the parking lot damn
poor guy 90-minute way you finish as
quickly as possible and leave the
building to scan the parking lot for
your brother's car but you see but you
don't see his old Civic anywhere you
pass by a blue Camaro and jump isn't
beeps that you causing you to jump and
surprise it takes you a moment it takes
you a moment for to realize it but it's
Malcolm in the driver's seat you hop in
the passenger seat and compliment him on
his new ride and he mentions that it's a
perk of a promotion he's recently
obtained work bastard [ __ ] he
starts telling you what if he's got the
same work that we tariff yeah he's gonna
promotion it like the same like low
level job you do he starts telling you
about how much more money he's making
how his career is really taking off and
how he's starting to look at houses with
his wife soon I hope number one or I
hope number three because that's the one
that isn't crossed out is kill him xxxx
hey it's pot this could take a turn man
and that would be acting out especially
now in the public discussion where it's
like I was reading something earlier
today about like our sort of warped view
on depression in society and how it's
either like like I you suck it up or
you're insane yeah um I like your son I
like your strap eula extrapolate strap
eula you strap you like my scheduling
you extrapolate your scapula you crunch
the bag containing the night garden your
hand and feel yourself clench your teeth
as you think of your crummy apartment
and how long it's been since you've been
able to take a day off work without
having to worry about making ends meet
he's only two years older than you but
it feels like he's eons ahead of you and
every other respect of your lives so he
asks how did your appointment go did you
get drilled full of holes or what a
sense of shame creeps over you do you
not one why is our brother such a dick
so I'd your point Miguel Oh Bree you did
your head drill Foles me cuz you got
holes in your your head cuz you [ __ ] is
a tall hygiene it should yet your work
getting my Camaro get in my Camaro and
let talk to you about how much money i
mean i'm going to buy a house with my
wife I can't be that oblivious to the
point that I don't know that you kind of
relating an unsatisfying life right now
so do you not do one laughs about your
dorky night guard with your brother to
tell him about the night garden why you
needed neither are options three you
could lie and tell him it was a routine
cleaning or four tell him about your
tooth grinding problem but not distress
causing it oh man that's hard actually I
would say yeah yeah yeah probably yeah
it's all about your tooth grinding
problem but not the stress causing it
get on grindr the dentist said I'm
apparently grinding my teeth too much
when I sleep Oh Malcolm replies been
stressed out lately kiddo deciding that
you don't really want to go into it you
tell them that you don't think it's
that's the case and it's probably just a
random thing he doesn't pride farther
and instead begins reminiscing with you
about the time you chipped a baby tooth
because he accidentally knocked you over
once you go out for dinner and catch up
on things but you still feel somewhat
distracted by the non anxiety in the
back of your mind though you enjoy your
brother's company you still feel like
you want nothing more than to go home
and hide from the world tonight it
becomes hard for you to try and stuff
all of your horrible feelings down and
go emotionless when someone like the
dentist can see a fraction of what goes
on inside your head it leaves you
feeling embarrassed in a week and you
hate yourself for feeling that way do
you wonder if you're really fooling
anyone into think
you're a normal person and then wonder
if your brother knows and is hanging out
with you out of pity tonight after he
drops you back off at your apartment you
throw the night guard out you can't
stand to even look at the thing dude
that was probably expensive all right
well maybe we have a church maybe this
is in Canada is molded to our teeth
which is actually kind of fun whenever
they've got that like pink [ __ ] out what
molded I never has it has it done I
never I'd like an icar but they would
mold you for like retainers and [ __ ]
yeah whose people to dry Sunday but we a
lot of sunday yeah which is my least
favorite days good this is good yeah
basically it's almost like though the
week just kind of blurs into this
recursive cycle of Sunday's where it's
like oh god I don't want to go back to
work tomorrow and then occasionally the
Monday was I I know we haven't had a
casual Tuesday in a while you grabbed a
is the dry Sunday morning you grab your
morning coffee and scoot your rapidly
growing kitten off your is growing at an
alarming rate it's so big oh no it's
bigger than the fridge uh you scoot your
rapidly growing cat off your office
chair and despite her protests sit down
at your desk to check your email a new
message pops up in your inbox almost as
soon as you do it's from Amanda and you
remember your meeting in the cafe and
awkwardly bringing up your feelings to
her subject hey buddy body hey sorry
it's been a few weeks I meant to get
this to you sooner but it took a while
for me to get ahold of my folks back
home dad told me to say hi by the way
anyway I remember uh what we talked
about last time i saw you and i hope you
are insulted but i asked my mom for the
number of her for her therapist don't
worry i didn't tell her who was for I
think she's worried about me now though
haha anyway the number is 6 47 72 35 274
it's a really good office you should
look into it talking to someone never
hurts if you're worried about money
don't be there one the few that has
really good sliding scale fee system and
will charge you anything you can't
afford I hope you're feeling better it
was really nice to see you again eh hey
come on we thought
cheer up yo it's still early enough that
you could call and make an appointment
today you're kidding curls up in your
lap as you consider what to do but
you're not gonna do number one call the
therapist number you're looking forward
to the help you think they can offer and
you're not gonna new number to try
you're looking call the number even
though the mere thought of talking to
someone makes you anxious she cared
enough to send it to you after all three
sleep on it see how you're feeling in
the morning you're not keen on the idea
at all but you don't want to disappoint
Amanda for close the email without
thinking more of it this has been
embarrassing enough already I our soft
let's call the number and see what
happens just my [ __ ] yeah call the
number oh right now yeah alright I'm
afraid what if we have to start
confessing our our innermost stresses
and anxieties put it for us put on a
speaker what if it's like for like a
band what if it's a spiral marketing and
weird band oh man Surata dossier for
more information we need the full
exercise one it's an active part i am is
even actually therapists office in
toronto why it's an actual therapists
office in toronto well done wow I mean I
figured it had to link to something
relevant but yeah well I was addressing
like maybe it was like it's just a
standing fake like promo number for
something but I didn't think or just
like a general like depression helpline
yeah that is interesting i guess it's
legit office I feel like I would go with
three yeah like I'd still be like like I
don't want to do now cuz it's to like go
home
to whatever but yeah but I wouldn't just
be up mm-hmm 33 Trey pace all right the
thought of picking up the phone and
calling someone about this right now is
overwhelming sure you're having a hard
time lately and have motivation issues
but you really are but are you really in
need of therapy and shouldn't you be
able to just get over it yourself what
if they put you on medication that makes
you feel like a zombie what if you go
and the therapist looks down on you well
Alex think about this trying to think
about all these things at once makes it
feel like a very big deal and you decide
to take your time and think on it the
rest of the day passes quickly and that
night you have a hard time trying to
sleep because your brain is too busy
thinking about all these things and
imagining all the ways it could go
horribly wrong the next morning you
check your email again with blurry eyes
and a mewing kitten Amanda's email is
still there seemingly waiting for you
you are no more decided than you were
yesterday what now one just call ready
he can't hurt to check it out but we
can't do that but we could do to call
after wrestling with it for a few
minutes longer three don't call this is
way too much for you to be able to deal
with right now well no man is truth
maybe it's a good sign to see that only
one option is xed out yeah so I say too
yeah I do too yeah you read through
Amanda's email two or three times and
sit and stare at your computer for a
while while the memory of that
uncomfortable conversation makes you
feel newly embarrassed in self conscious
part of you is also encouraged by the
fact that you cared enough to get back
to you at all just sitting in front of
your computer you start to question
things like whether or not Amanda sent
you this number out of pity or perhaps
some sense of obligation after having
listened to you your question or motors
in the valve and the validity of her
concern and whether or not you think
seeing a therapist would even be helpful
yet almost unconsciously you reach for
your phone and before you realize what's
happening you're listening to the
therapists line ring
before you can bring yourself to hang up
your listening to the slightly clinical
but not unpleasant voice of the
receptionist asked how she can help you
I like to make an appointment with the
doctor it managed to stammer out the
conversation is quick and not nearly as
unpleasant as you were fearing and
quicker than you can say Freudian slip
you've scheduled an appointment quicker
than you realize appointment Day rolls
around what do you do create your own
line of novelty post-it notes called
Freudian slips if so it's not a real
option but you know what is an unreal
option in context is number one go to
the therapists office we do not have
that as an option number two we do head
to the therapists office even though
you're totally unsure of what to expect
three sit in your car terrified and
tried to talk yourself into or out of
going number four just the thought of
going to your appointment ties your
stomach in knots you crawl back into bed
okay I would probably do too I mean we
would but two is the best option
available I mean I feel like at this
point I mean yeah and then this is a
portrait of your your thought process as
well but you know like we are kind of
deciding how just how depressed our site
for his right now yeah I mean it's not
clearly not so far gone that too is no
longer an option yeah yeah sames is so
let's go with to that yeah killer Jim
killer you have your first session with
your new therapist dr. Susan Melville
daughter of Herman mmm a tall woman
hasn't of Moby Moby's dick sorry a tall
woman in her mid 40s with a disarming
demeanor and patient eyes with the start
of the slightest smile lines she makes
you feel comfortable fairly easily which
is a pleasant surprise after all of your
anxiety over the appointment as you
leave you make your second appointment
you're still skeptical about all of this
but figure you might as well see where
this goes the hardest part it seems
taking the first step you're still not
sure if and how you're going to tell
your family or your partner but you
figure you'll deal with that when the
time
comes either way you feel relieved that
you managed to see this through instead
of being paralyzed with worry over it
even if nothing comes of it you did
something you said you would and instead
of flaking out a running away you're
emotionally exhausted when you get home
and collapse into bed you sleep better
that night than you have in a week and
you're not sure if it's because you were
so tired when you got home or if it's
because of the therapist very little
detail on how the appointment goes well
you know it's your first appointments
usually you know just like tell me about
yourself yeah like let's let's see if we
can establish a rapport and maybe
address the the surface yeah it's all
very rapport building oh we got a
Wednesday a Wednesday holy [ __ ] it's not
a I'm gonna be going up on a Wednesday
going up on a Wednesday it is early on a
wednesday morn up Oh Tuesday Thank You
Cal Thank You Cal Cheston it is early on
a Wednesday morning lately you've
developed a nasty habit of waking up 10
to 20 minutes before your alarm rings
and unfortunately today is no exception
you lay in bed each minute taking closer
and closer to wake up time and passing
on a swelling wave of ever encroaching
dread sooner than you would like your
alarm blares with caustic inevitability
you frantically pound the snooze button
and then retreat under your bra blankets
as if the warmth of your comforter can
shield you from the passage of time you
almost always have difficulty rising
from bread but today that simple task
seems nothing short of Hercule and after
several snooze cycles you decide that
you can't you just can't deal with work
today incapable of human browsing
yourself from bed let alone going into
work and having to force yourself
through a workday not to mention you
snooze so many times that would be
impossible to make it on in on time now
anyways what do you do not hop out of
bed and start getting ready for work
you'll be late but it's better than not
going at all to head into work at least
you can leave early if it gets too
unbearable three call your boss to tell
them that you're sick and won't be in
today you are very depressed you spend a
large amount of time sleeping hitting
yourself in that very little energy or
motivation so I feel like we've gone
down we've he's actually we were more we
started off at this level and then we
dipped further down and now we're back
up at the level we started hmm that cat
didn't do [ __ ] you spent some time out
there episc ouch you're having
difficulty finding the motivation to
continue going to your sessions well um
I feel like head into work yeah I feel
like I'd want to call out but I would
just be like I have to go to work yeah I
would want to call out but it's also
like it's it's too close to when you
would have to be in any way to like make
calling out not be a big deal ya gotta
be spots yeah in spite of the fact that
your body is actively fighting you
literally every step of the way you
somehow manage to drag yourself out of
bed and make your way into work
surprisingly you end up being about five
minutes late you owe you end up only
being about five minutes Layton's not
that bad and nobody seems to notice or
care though when you woke up uh though
when you woke up the simple act of even
being even physically president your job
seemed like an impossibility you are
surprised at your own ability to push on
through the day while you are far from
enjoying or indeed even really coping
with the dullness of your job today you
seem to have slipped into a trance-like
state of awe Tom automation uh and time
is never is nevertheless passing
eventually the end of the day rolls
around and you head home utterly
exhausted but at the same time almost
proud of yourself from having stuck it
out wait you are depressed interaction
is exhausting and you're becoming more
and more withdrawn they were seeing a
therapist even though you doubt anything
she says could me feel better you're not
currently taking medication for his
number one head didn't we see this
before or did we not only have we come
back to hear I feel like I feel like
we've roads a little bit or not we're
just baseline depressed now we're not
super depressed we don't have depressed
certain we don't have depression picante
we don't hate our
yone this one but I think I feel like
we've seen this exact phrase or yeah I
feel like that exact phrase has been
incorporated into a longer message so we
still have that symptom interaction
still rough but the show to Oh God oh
we're just a lot of red at the bottom of
all but one options oh god it's 2 a.m.
on a sunday it's 2 a.m. on a sunday and
you have work in the morning boy howdy
let's see how this one goes you roll
over to see the sickly green glow of the
time displayed on your LED on our clock
and let out an exasperated sigh you've
been trying to fall asleep for over
three hours now to no avail every time
your head hits the pillow you're
overcome with anxious thoughts that wrap
themselves around each other worries
about your job lead to worries about
your future li2 worries about your very
identity and you're unable to shake them
off long enough to doze off your eyes
won't even stay shut as your mind races
through imagine scenarios going horribly
wrong it would you promptly attribute to
your general worthlessness or your
thoughts run too fast for you to come to
a satisfying conclusion on any one of
them the room is completely silent but
the silence is given way to a loud
static noise rattling around inside your
head your heart beats loudly and you
worry it's the it's beating a little too
fast you worry that if you focus too
strongly on your racing heart you'll
freak yourself hard you'll freak
yourself out hard enough that you have a
heart attack you have to be awake for
work in the mirror eight hours you know
that your work is so much worse on only
a few hours sleep what do you do are we
still just depressed or do we have an
anxiety disorder or will that be a plot
twist on the way I think maybe the
depression based on how you deal with a
can't trigger moments of anxiety oh so
what do you do not much apparently
number one which we won't be doing is
force yourself to sleep also number to
go to bed it shouldn't be that hard also
number three just close your eyes and
let it happen why won't your thoughts
back off for five seconds number four
nogo snap out of it what is wrong with
you why can't you stop stressing out for
five seconds number five also know
though you're probably
to go into work tomorrow exhausted and
[ __ ] everything up and get fired huh the
options here actually hurt it's like
your attitude is seeping into the
options way thicker than as before yeah
number six go to your computer sleep is
clearly not happening no matter how long
you lay here that you are depressed
interaction is exhausting and you are
becoming more and more withdrawn you are
seeing a therapist even though you doubt
anything she says can make you feel
better you want you currently taking
medications so I guess we only have one
choice yeah so next time on dank ass
stubs fine we're going to go to the
computer going to the computer the
exciting I don't probably not the
conclusion because this would be really
bad conclusions we sit in front of
computer forever until we die until we
die yeah but the exciting continuation
of depression quest on take a stubs will
continue when name bat-time same
bat-channel so stay tuned for for going
to the computer are going to the
computer and until then stay stay stay
depressed face as they said just stay in
your bed forever but hey I mean you know
as long as you're in bed once you make
yourself a thick juicy steak yeah she
just like goes better with the thick
juicy steak then a marinade by Frank a
stairs why gasps rounds and mine
seasonings herbs the spices and your
next shindig we have we have a exciting
new announcement Frank a stubs flank ass
rubs is now the official spice source
for the meats on hook exhibition / food
court at at Terry's spooky days I love
it when when two of our sponsors get
together and form just a baby of
Industry yeah it's going to be it's
going to be that it's gonna be cool so
tune in so tune in next time and
remember kids stay Frank and once again
there i'm gerry and he's Aaron and I'm
Jared and he's Jerry and I'm Aaron and
we're all Jerry stage a won't you
signing off